[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as
they arrive in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author christina
patterson and former advisor to boris
johnson
colbert ranger so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the sun leading with the headline matt
finished
and the news of matt hancock's departure
from his position as health secretary
the mirror also running with the same
headline referring to the health
secretary and his aides
sudden exit
gone hancock quits after day of
humiliation
that's the headline in the observer
the telegraph leads on matt hancock's
statement about
sticking to his own covet guidelines
and the express also going with that and
the headline hancock
forced to quit
tears of a clown that's the headline for
the star
the time says humiliated hancock quits
and includes the claim that the former
health secretary ended his marriage just
hours before
his affair was exposed and on the front
of the mail hancock quits
his job and marriage
we're joined tonight by christina
patterson and colbert
ranger welcome to both of you we'll um
start with that
observer uh front page hancock quits
after day of humiliation
um christina did he have any other
option
not by this point he didn't know because
uh the support had drained away
from the party from mps and from the
public and i think many
and tory mps have been keeping quiet
about it do you remember when the
dominic cummings uh affair
happened last may then uh there were all
these staged
uh tweets of support from across the
spectrum but
this time none of that and uh they
feared it was already turning into
a barnard castle situation and he had to
go
i mean you know he clearly unfortunately
is um a lying cheat and hypocrite
and uh he had no choice because he told
the whole country that
we were not allowed to even hug people
outside our household
let alone do what he was apparently
doing
in that footage but i think
well at this time you know he did have
to go but i just feel
desperately sorry for his wife and
children i i think
you know even when someone goes when
it's clear they do have to go
it's never you can't just sit and gloat
because there are
people whose lives have been blown apart
by this actually
and my heart just goes out to his family
and his wife who
must be going through absolute hell at
the moment
cool but he did initially say that uh
when he apologized that he wanted to
stay he wanted to
continue what he had started and bring
the country out of the
pandemic um he had the confidence of the
prime minister what do you think changed
well i think you know i've known matt
hancock for a number of years actually
since he worked for george osborne
and you know he's a he's a hugely
um detailed committed uh politician
he has been all his life uh and i think
it's hard when you're at the center of a
storm or something like this
uh to see what's actually happening
around you the full consequence when it
becomes so
personal and so associated with you and
at that point i think you lose a bit of
perspective so i think
there's a period of time uh when
something like this happens
where the people that are right at the
center of it aren't really fully aware
of what the impact it's the impact it's
happening
having around them and in the broader
environment and as that becomes
clearer i think it dawns on them
situation and that's why he has done
exactly the right thing today and
resigned and uh
christina we we know that um
although he has uh apologized i mean
that there have been
uh personal developments um we believe
that
it is officially now a separation from
his wife the
the personal side is as you alluded to
before is where you really do feel
sympathy for all those
involved absolutely and
to be informed that your husband has
been having an affair
but you're only being informed because
it's about to hit all the headlines
must be absolutely dreadful and one of
the reports says that matt hancock woke
up his eight-year-old daughter i think
this in the sunday times
to tell her that he was leaving their
mother i mean devastating for the
children so
yes there are always you know
people humans at the heart of a
situation like this and
my heart absolutely goes out to them but
i do find it of course it's an
incredibly stressful job and
people do fall in love with other people
but i just think the
abject hypocrisy of the whole thing is
quite breathtaking
and the fact that he wasn't going to
resign any
honorable anyone with a shred of honor
would have
resigned well frankly anyone with a
shred of honor wouldn't have been
operating with such hypocrisy even if
they'd fall in love with someone
they wouldn't have been actively as has
allegedly been the case conducting an
affair under the noses
of their colleagues and staff while
standing on a platform almost
every day saying you must not reach the
guidelines and not just guidelines
according to one report the reason he
had to resign was because there were
reports of police having to look into it
this is not just
guidance this is the law people were
being
fined 10 000 pounds or at least having
the threat of 10 000
fines for breaking the law on this so it
is
pretty breathtaking and very upsetting
when so many people have made such
enormous sacrifices during this time
weddings cancelled funerals not allowed
to happen
wakes tiny i had my brother's
wake in november and we had
four of us standing by the grave we
couldn't even go to a pub
for lunch but we know what matt hancock
was doing i'm sorry but it makes me
absolutely furious christina i'm so
sorry to hear about uh
your loss um cool there
i suppose matt hancock has admitted to
that that hypocrisy
we see in the sunday telegraph the
headline there those of us who make
these rules
have got to stick by them so in the end
he was admitting that
he had been a complete hypocrite uh
he has he he has owned up he has
apologized but i think
he has also resigned and he has done the
honorable thing
but i i agree with christina there'll be
a lot of people
in the country who'd be very angry
because they looked
to the secretary of state for leadership
they looked to the secretary of state
for confidence in his decision-making
and trusting him
in terms of what their he was telling
them and and i think
firstly he has had the pressure of this
of managing this uh this pandemic and i
think the job
has been the hardest job in government
over the last year enough and i'm not
sure any health secretary will
ever have faced anything like it and
it's still a relatively young age
um but there's no excuses you know he's
been at the center of this
he he has done the best he can to manage
it and i think the country has
acknowledged
um probably the good work as the prime
minister did in responding to his
resignation letter that he's done in his
achievements
um not only now in the pandemic but
going forward in gaining the biggest
ever spending agreement for the nhs
that there has ever been and and that is
going to be his legacy but unfortunately
this will cast a huge shadow on what
he's done at this stage
because the trust that he was uh
he was responsible for with the british
public has has been severely broken by
by this uh
this human act of his and we do have to
to bear in mind
we want politicians to be absolutely
perfect but they're not robots
they will reflect society society is
never perfect
and they will make mistakes and he has
made a fundamental mistake
and i think uh you know the the
consequences for him
but yes as christine is saying
absolutely for the families involved
uh are are what we also should care
about at this point
um and probably give them that time that
they'll need after this and i think he
personally i know needs some time to
take a break as well
uh many saying that you know his credit
credibility has been completely
uh destroyed all and future career
possibly although the prime minister in
his letter to him said you should be
immensely proud of your service
i'm grateful for your support and
believe that your contribution to public
service
is far from over that's from the prime
minister but the sun headline
is saying matt finished christina
well of course he's not finished i mean
if there were any
if honor was something that mattered in
the politics of this country then
clearly we wouldn't have boris johnson
as our prime minister
um ethical matters are of minuscule
concern tim
we know that when pretty patel was found
to have bullied
staff then in an independent report he
just dismissed the report and kept her
on
we know that when robert generic
breached regulations he kept him on
uh this is not a government that holds
honor very high
and uh boris johnson i think in spite of
what dominic cummings said um in his
leaked well in actually in his in his
leaked whatsapp messages
boris johnson i think probably does have
quite a lot of respect for matt hancock
he's a hard worker if nothing else and
um
also i think boris johnson is someone
who doesn't like being told what to do
so
having he wouldn't he won't like the
fact that his own authority has been
undermined in this and
he will probably be quite keen to have
matt hancock back at some stage so
i don't think we need to weep too many
tears about matt hancock's political
future at this point
okay christina and colbert stay right
there we are going to take a break
coming up after the break sergey javid
returns to the cabinet we'll be
discussing
all of that and more do stay with us
we're desperately trying to make england
um
the first country in the world that by
2030 has zero new
hiv transmissions now it's a very brave
thing to do but i think when you're
setting targets
it's very important that you set very
brave brave targets and i think to do
that
we need to raise the awareness around
hiv and the understanding because we're
from tackle hiv we've recently done a
new survey and we understood from that
survey
that nearly half the people who we
surveyed
thought that they didn't need to take
part in a hiv
testing day because they felt they were
at risk of hiv now that assume or that
assumption then
means that people assume that people who
are affected by hiv are just people from
the lgbtq plus community or black
african men black african women
and that and that really isn't true that
really isn't
isn't factual so it's a you know for us
to get to that
brave target for that to get to for us
to get to
england being the first country with
either new hiv transmissions we need
everybody to be tested therefore we need
to
eradicate the fear of testing the
reality is is that
you know from 30 40 years ago when uh
the public health warning was put out
and people felt like at that moment
they learned and understood everything
they needed to know around hiv
and around aids and the reality is is
that kind of underground
in the last 30 40 years science medicine
has moved on and advanced so
dramatically that i
as somebody now living with hiv can live
a very happy normal healthy life taking
one tablet
a day but the reality is is that people
feel
that they already know because of what
they learned 30 40 years ago
and it's very it's very difficult to
re-educate people
on on a subject that they already know
about or also to get them to converse
about a subject that actually they don't
really want to talk about
because it's kind of it's always been
shrouded in a bit of a mystery it's all
been shouted in darkness
we need to celebrate where we are at the
moment with um
people who are on the medicine about
living with hiv
we need we need to be able to celebrate
how advanced and how far
medication has come but sadly so many
people still
think and act in the way that people did
30 or 40 years ago and
and you know that's that's something we
need to really work on to change
[Music]
we are at a breaking point and we need
to work
now and fast even though young people
are vulnerable
to the importance of climate change
young people can also become the change
agents that we need to address the
climate impact
in my campaign or in advocacy work i
work entirely with young people so that
their voices can be heard so they can
also influence decision making
from the local level to the national
level and thankfully we are making
progress in a regard
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview still with me journalist and
author christina patterson and former
advisor to boris johnson
colvier ranger uh let's uh go to you
first of all culver we have a look at
the daily mail
and the headline there hancock quits his
job and
marriage um but they're also throwing
ahead to the new health secretary
sajid javid making a dramatic comeback
they say
would you agree you know the inner
workings of the conservative party
yes well it appears sajid was not so
much far away but on the sub bench it's
been well
uh known in westminster the prime
minister was keen to have him back
he's hugely respected he's already
previously been uh
business secretary home secretary and
chancellor
unfortunately lost that battle with uh
one dominic cummings
um when he lost the when he stepped away
from being chancellor
uh and i think that there was always
felt there was unfinished business
um he has a lot to add he has a lot of
experience
and i think as we all know probably the
job in government as we continue to go
through this pandemic
as someone with this much experience
could not be ignored for the role so
that's why i think the prime minister
has made the decision to bring him back
christine in the meanwhile uh mentioning
dominic cummings there as uh colvier did
he's tweeted tonight
saying uh hashtag need regime change
that um sajid javid is simply more of
the same
well i agree with dominic cummings about
the need for regime change but the fact
that he was
a very very central plank if not the
second
second most central plank in that regime
slightly undermines his message it's a
very nasty tweet actually
he implied that had sajid javid remained
at the treasury then the whole thing
would have been a mess there would have
been no furlough
that that his special advisers were
hopeless as we know
um one of uh his dominic cummings
i think was um lost in employment
tribunal and i may have got this wrong
against
uh one of um sajid javid's aides who
dominic cummings fired
for no uh ostensible reason so i mean
you know nasty piece of work dominic
cummings but even
nasty people can tell the truth from
time to time and i think
a lot of what he has said in that select
committee and
in releasing his whatsapp groups and on
his incredibly verbose blog
has the ring of truth but my feeling
about sajid javid
is that he is a man of integrity and not
least because
while practically everybody else in the
cabinet took
every compromise that came their way
swiftly
dropped their allegiance in terms of the
referendum claimed they'd been born
again brexiteers from the beginning like
liz trust who was of course
remain supported before she became a
born-again brexiter he
actually had the integrity to resign
when he was told he wouldn't be able to
keep
his team of aid so um i you know who
knows how he'll do the job but i think
he
is a man of integrity he's a man of
honor he's very capable
and he knows this is a very big job so
fingers crossed because it couldn't be
more important the pandemic is not over
tragically and let's hope that he
does a good job cool very quickly we're
running out of time but back to the um
sunday times
and they've got a story about colin
hancock using a private
email when he should have actually been
using an official email for covid
business
yeah julian you know as soon as um
secretary's estate ministers leave their
roles all kinds of stories come out
um and this one about private email i
know for a fact that matt hancock was
um quite surprised shocked at the
antiquated state of some of the
technology in the nhs he wanted to move
that forward i think there was something
around
how he wanted to use different types of
platforms
um but he was always someone who was
ruffling feathers in terms of wanting
progress i think
you know full of beans was how he's
described um i think christina said
and i agree with that he will be back
he's probably got a lot still to give
he's still a relatively young man
so you know i think he needs to learn
from this situation
uh take stock um look what happens with
and around his personal life
but he will come back and i think he's
done still got a lot to give to this
government and this country and
hopefully
um that will help him going forward
culver and christina thank you both